[Opening theme]
All right! Let's get the obvious out of the way:
The first rule of Fight Club is:
"You do not talk about fight club."
The SECOND rule of Fight Club is:
"You DO NOT talk about Fight Club."
K?
K.
We're gonna talk about Fight Club.
Released in 1999, directed by David Fincher, and adapted from the novel by Chuck Pollinick,
Fight Club is an ultraviolent reflection on masculinity, media, corporate culture, gender relationships, self-identity, fatherhood,
and the conflict between individualism and collectivism.
Fight Club, intentionally or not, exposes the crisis of masculine identity as the 'hetero-white-male is displaced' as the societal default,
and the ugly, hazardous reactions to that loss of unquestioned power.
As we go through Fight Club, I want to hone the focus to how men interact with each other
and with the concept of what it means to be a man, the societal construct, the
collective idea that pops into everyone's head when we think of a "real man."
Also, from here on out, when I refer to 'Fight Club' I am, more often than not, referring to the organization within the movie, and not the movie itself.
The first thing that we need to get on the table is the notion of toxic masculinity.
The common misinterpretation of this phrase is that it's being used to condemn all masculinity,
as though manhood itself is something inherently bad,
Well, this is not true.
Toxic masculinity refers to things that are typically encoded as positive or natural masculine traits that are -
under a more critical look -
actually damaging to self and surrounding.
For example:
"Why? I don't know why. I don't know - never been in a fight. You?"
"No, but that-that's a good thing."
"No it is not. How much can you know about yourself if you've never been in a fight?"
Toxic masculinity is a social script, that tells men and boys that the right way to be a man is to be violent, emotionally unavailable, sexually agressive and soforth.
It's a narrow, confining definition of a man that shuts off a vast range of human experiences
and marginalizes the men who fail to conform to that societal standard.
It tells them what pursuits are worthy, what styles are acceptable.
How a man walks, talks and looks -
Society is structured to reward men who follow the script, and marginalizes those who don't.
For example, aggression and hostility are held up as macho standards-
natural, if not desirable traits for men to have, despite their overwhelmingly negative impact on people, groups and society.
This has two operative effects:
First, in lionizing and rewarding aggression,
and second, in diminishing passivity.
For an incredibly real example of the damage that lionizing aggression can cause,
look no further than investment banking, an industry that attracts and rewards aggression like no other.
Passive manner, depicted as lesser, as weaker, as compromised, fake men victimized by society,
and the path to self-acceptance is through the primal embrace of violence.
Take for example, the priest who is recruited into Fight Club.
Yeah! Yeah!
[other men cheer]
Or, in my own life, when discussing this episode's writing on Twitter,
Adam Baldwin sent me this image of macho-Putin punching jet fighters out of the air,
contrasted against what I can only assume is a weak-huggy-feeling Obama.
Attached was the message, "Toxic masculinity greater than hashtag New Castrati."
So, this is kindof why this is proven to be such a deep-seated issue in society.
The people most invested in the macho identity are actively, knowingly promoting it, and defending it from change or criticism.
This narrow masculine script is often presented as naturalistic, or a "biotruth."
Something that's an emergent property of biology and thus immune to criticism.
The examples of this are long and many:
"Boys will be boys,"
"Men think about sex every 7 seconds"
"Men can't be friends with women because every man wants to have sex with every woman"
The idea that a "real man" is prepared and willing to get violent at a moments notice,
And so on and so on and so on.
Now, to be clear here, the problem is not in 'being sexual' or being sexually forward,
No one is saying that men should become celibate monks, only donating sperm as needed to perpetuate the species,
The problem is believing that male sexuality is inherently forward and that men are, by nature, unstoppable sex fiends
Not only is this limiting of men, who, say, aren't all that interested in sex,
or who prefer to take a more passive role in their sexual encounters,
It also creates an environment of entitlement, by imbuing sexual aggression with a sort of inevitability.
Ideas like "Men can't be friends with women, because he will inevitably try to have sex with her."
Or far worse ideas that trot dubiously along the boundaries of consent.
This then cuts both ways, demonizing men as rapists-in-training, such as we saw in 'She's Out of Control."
"Okay, I get it."
"You want it to be MY fault. I'll do a little...
"...grabbing, you'll do a little...
"..protesting-Okay! Okay, I got it. Alright"
[exasperated] "Timit(?) stop it."
[sighs] "It's my first time."
"I'd like it to be special."
"Now take me home."
[huffs with amusement]
"You, teasing. little. bitch."
And dismissing the role of agency in men who commit sexual violence encapsulated in the all-too typical post-rape response,
"What did you think would happen?"
As though being raped is an inescapable, natural consequence of being off-guard around men.
So, yes, the issue of Toxic Masculinity isn't merely one of pop-culture interest.
It's a very real subject with tangible society-altering implications.
'Fight Club,' the film, is a confused, messy celebration and self-condemnation of the worst of what masculinity has to offer.
It revels in the violence that rips itself apart.
It is, in many ways, constrained by the macho ideals that it criticizes-
drunk on the power trip of violence and hedonism,
all the while being unable to escape the damage being done.
The narrator, who we'll refer to as Jack, is our modern put-upon everyman.
He has followed the societal script: grown up, gone to college, gotten a degree, got a job, has an apartment filled with furniture and...
now what?
"I can't get married."
"I'm a 30-year-old boy."
Consumerism and being a corporate drone have failed to fill the void of community.
At first, he fills this with support groups, posing as someone with, quote "real problems," in order to find human connections through shared suffering.
Something worth noting, here, is the downplay of the ennui that Jack is facing.
His problems, his uncertainty, his identity crisis, though completely isolating, damaging and toxic...
...aren't seen as valid.
Here is, in a sense, our carry-over theme from the last episode:
Jack recognizes that he is privileged
that the world revolves around him as a
Jack recognizes that he is priviledged, that the world revolves around him as a demographic, and yet he's still unahppy.
"I wasn't a host to cancer, or parasites.
"I was the warm little center that the life of this world crowded around."
And, yeah, he kinda blames women.
"We're a generation of men raised by women.
"I'm wondering if another woman is really the answer we need."
The enemy, in the end, is his own macho expectations for himself and the world.
It's telling, and intentional, that the first place Jack visits as a misery tourist, and where he almost learns how to let go,
is in a support group for men with testicular cancer.
These are,  many of them, literally Castrati.
Societally, they are lesser men, and that pain runs through their dialogue.
Most notably, the man speaking about his lost dreams of a family.
"With her uh....her new husband."
"Thank god, y'know?"
I'm glad for her.
[breaking down crying] because she deserves...
And within that, within the fake identity of a person with incurable disease,
Jack is able to find a measure of fufillment, a connection with other people  however facile it may be.
Over the course of the first act, these two themes,
the dehumanizing corporate consumer lifestyle and the sense of emasculation are then intwined.
Passive-aggressive corporate culture is equated with a perceived feminization of society.
TYLER: We're a generation of men raised by women.
TYLER: I'm wondering if another woman is really the answer that we need.
The antidote, Tyler proposes, is to reclaim some notion of true, primal manhood  through blood and sweat and..
Fight Club is born.
A refuge for seemingly marginalized men looking to reclaim their manhood.
The irony is, of course, that all of these men were already macho.
They're already resentful and angry and ready to do violence -
they're merely looking for permission.
After all,
Who else would Fight Club appeal to?
Can I be next?
Despite the proposed desire to reclaim some lost manhood,
Tyler Durden is already the idealized macho man.
Well, I dunno.
You tell me, considering that Tyler Durden looks like this.
I mean, this is explicit text,
TYLER: I look like you wanna look, I fuck like you wanna fuck, I'm smart.
TYLER: I am smart, capable, and most importantly:
TYLER: I'm free in all the ways that you are not.
See, there's this language there:
JACK: That what a man looks like?
[laughs]
Case in point:
Bob never really belongs in Fight Club.
He doesn't see his emasculation as a spiritual one or even one that really makes him less of a man.
Explained in their first meeting, Bob knows full well that his testicular cancer was the by-product of  the steroids he was using.
Her pursued the hypermasculine ideal and it literally destroyed his manhood.
But he is, to a point, at peace with that.
His life goes on, a little dumb, a little gullible.
He joins Fight Club seemingly as a game, titilated by the 'secret club' aspect.
BOB: I'm not supposed to talk about it.
BOB: and the second rule is-
When he first applies to Project Mayhem, he's rejected, as all candidates are, and simply accepts this,
picks up his things and heads home, until cajoled into staying by Jack.
Bob is, within this limited scope, our 'enlightened' man.
The one who is more or less okay with himself, and  isn't troubled that he doesn't conform with the ideal.
He's a little lonely, and a little dumb, but that's about it.
In grand tragedy, he is persuaded into going along with Project Mayhem, and pays for it with his life.
The paradox that the film presents is that,
in attempting to get away from the society that has exploited, dehumanized, and marginalized them,
in attempting to reclaim individuality and
identity,
they replicate the very same exploitative and dehumanizing systems in
their own microcosm to the point of
Fight Club you have to fight
commercialism and violence are both
presented as the appropriately masculine
identity markers the uniform that all
members must adopt to show their
allegiance to the group at work you wear
a suit and tie at Fight Club
man lose the tie no shirts no shoes in
attempting to escape what is presented
as an emasculating corporate system
Project Mayhem simply recreates it in
miniature members of Project Mayhem are
literally stripped of their names until
they can be mythologized as martyrs
Project Mayhem is franchised an
international corporation led
autocratically by the mythological Tyler
Durden
this is a running theme of the film
where Jack consistently latches on to
the outer trappings of systems and
structures and abuse them with spiritual
power remaining uncritical of the
underlying systems when he threw tyler
durden invents Fight Club and Project
Mayhem the problem from his point of
view
isn't that the macho ideals were always
unattainable garbage a product based
identity that they were sold just the
same as the coffee table shaped like a
yin-yang the problem is that it wasn't
delivered in the form they wanted that
life being rock gods and movie stars was
entitled to them slowly learning of that
very very pissed off Fight Club is in
essence not a rejection of the status
quo but a distillation of it the flaws
are not in the power structures and
exploitation not in the telling of the
myth but in who was chosen to sit on the
throne while Tyler rejects the trappings
90 fuckin kgs
he still embraces the myth itself who
they all sing we all dance and credit
the world
this is a cargo cult mentality this is
where I want to call attention back to
that first night with Bob at the
testicular cancer support group
surrounded by other men who did not fit
the script Society had written for them
Jack was able to let go if only for a
moment
but in that Jack sees only the trappings
of the support groups the ritual of
gathering and sharing weakness and
imbues that surface-level interaction
with power and begins to attend support
groups every evening of the week flight
club sees only the ritual of gathering
and sharing violence and abuse that
interaction with power there's a very
real replication of this that we see in
day-to-day life where underlying systems
are copied with only a change of paint
members assuming that the paint job was
the problem geek culture has a
problematic relationship with women look
at issues such as the conflict over
booth babes the very real need for
initiatives like cosplay is not consent
and
content documented by the editors at fat
ugly or slutty and yet they're still a
folk belief that geek culture doesn't
have a misogyny problem why well because
of a definition problem in their minds
these well-meaning people have equated
sexism with the heavy-handed
objectification they believe in body
Sports hip-hop and other mainstream pop
culture basically jock culture it's a
mistaken belief that those problems the
abuse and abuse of women the sexism the
intolerance are tied to the trappings of
the culture sport ball cheap beer and
fast cars the logic follows if I reject
sport ballin cars if I reject jock
culture than I have by nature rejected
misogyny and toxic masculinity that's
not true sports and cars and letterman
jackets and binge drinking in Cancun are
just the trappings the outer forms the
window dressing the actual problem is in
the core the narrow definitions of
acceptable masculinity the aggressive
policing of male identity the use of
misogynist and homophobic language to
disempower non-conforming men the sense
of natural entitlement to female
attention and a resentment of women who
break from the script it doesn't matter
if you've replaced sports cars with
league of Legends and Maxim with cutie
honey the power is not in the objects
the power is in the mentality online
space is still aggressively police
masculine identity and sexuality much
like the members of Fight Club chasing
the norms of a society that they claim
to reject oh into this sense of norms of
shared values it's driven home in the
bathroom scene where Project Mayhem
assaults the commissioner and threatens
to castrate him if he doesn't comply why
use that threat because it means just as
much to the mainstream as it means to
Project Mayhem and now I think we need
to talk about Marla Marla is the film
stand-in for women as a whole and is the
only woman with a speaking role past the
first act I mean that's kind of its own
can of worms but we're not going to go
there just because we don't have time
like really we just we don't have time
okay so Marla is the disrupting element
her mere presence of the support groups
calls attention to the myth and violates
the power of the illusion because Jack's
investment is only surface deep he is
incapable of connecting as long as she's
around because his ideal self is still
Tyler Durden that unconstrained violent
sex-crazed sociopath who is
simultaneously a rebel against
system and the embodiment of every value
the system olds dear ultimately Marla is
the expression of Jack's
inability to relate to women outside the
societal constructs both his
internalized concept of women as well as
his concepts of men the only women who
he can connect with albeit in a very
superficial way are nurturers motherly
figures with Marla who is practically
the antithesis of a nurturer he can only
interact with her in the context of
aggression or sex the only roles that
his internal macho ideal is capable of
Marla intruding into the testicular
cancer support group is this giant
symbol of women air-quote invading male
spaces and that disruption that ability
to go outside the feminine roles that
Jack feels she ought to be constrained
to makes him jealous envious and angry
because he feels constrained to his
spaces it exposes his own sense of
otherness his own position as someone
out of place in the circle of castrated
men and castration as we mentioned
before is a critical theme of the film
it's a symbol of male potency but a
symbol that only holds power if and when
potency is a desired value it's a social
construct through and through the
support group demonstrates this damage
of losing your testicles is primarily a
psychological one before we learn about
Bob's health condition once again damage
caused by steroid abuse in the pursuit
of a hyper masculine ideal were shown
the societal impact the man who feels
he's lost his place in the world because
he can't fulfill the narrative of a
white picket fence two boys and a girl
Tyler Durden aside these are our most
macho symbols of all in the film men who
within the construct of masculinity
failed they are emasculated and for the
most part are tormented by it but again
that paint only holds power if the loss
is valued being less macho is
devastating because these men see
themselves as having nowhere else to go
and that is the constraint the cage of
toxic masculinity then the movie goes
revolutionary
now this is complicated because it's not
something that is shall we say practical
as a real-world analog but it's a brave
idea operation mayhem recognizes that
without to total destruction of the
status quo the old forms will merely
rebirth themselves in the new operation
mayhem itself is as we've all
ready discussed a copycat of corporatism
built to destroy corporatism the only
solution so it proposes is a radical
deconstruction throwing everything away
and starting from scratch now the way
that this is proposed is explicitly
naturalistic in tone the clock will
rollback society will collapse in the
world will return to an agrarian ideal
where men can be real men however that's
not the way it can play out Tyler Durden
the embodiment of machismo is vital to
orchestrating the destruction of the old
world but is also a thing that is
unwelcome in the new the movie ends with
society collapsing embodied in the
crumbling of giant phallic buildings
then the motif is cemented by the
insertion of three frames of a flaccid
penis the real enemy is Tyler Durden the
fake invented internalized masculine
ideal he abuses Jack pressures him to
conform makes him self-destructive and
in basically every single way makes his
problems worse than they were before and
in those final moments after Tyler is
dead jack is finally able to connect
with Marla it's not even romantic or
sexual per se they don't kiss they just
reach out across that gap and hold hands
while the old system crumbles around
them only after Tyler is dead is Jack
able to be around Marla without it being
either sexual or confrontational only
then is he able to be something that is
outside the cage of being a real man and
here's the thing even though Jack was
pretender in the support groups even
though he was faking it it was working
the ability to open up to B sub ideal to
be less than whole and accepted well
babies don't sleep as well in contrast
the freedom of fight clubs toxic
machismo is I got right in everyone's
hostile little face yes these are
bruises from fighting yes I'm
comfortable with that I am enlightened
again this is not an indictment of being
a father of being strong of being a
protector of being sexual in fact there
are many many positive messages in
society that are strongly coded as
masculine honor respect Duty loyalty
honesty skills self-improvement
curiosity and every other Boy Scout
value is
something that our culture holds is
predominantly masculine I mean hell I
just refer to them as Boy Scout values
and those are absolutely positive strong
values that everyone can and should
aspire to but there are also toxic
values like violence sexual aggression
anger and combativeness and a narrow
inflexible social script that tells men
and boys that they must be providers or
they are failures they must be
protectors or they are failures they
must be number one because number two is
just the first loser
they must be horny or their lesser men
they must like competition or they are
weak case in point in response to last
episode I was sent this
right off the bat it's an assault on my
sexuality gay baiting and and attempted
undermining my manliness this isn't even
unusual the most common insults I
received over the last few months are
betta mangina pussy faggot and white
night
I've been called girl as an insult all
my life this is toxic masculinity this
is men attacking other men by accusing
them of being insufficiently macho it's
also misogynistic because it implies
that the worst thing a man can be is a
woman so what's the answer well it's
better role models it's calling out this
toxic behavior when we see it it's
dispelling harmful myths like boys will
be boys and holding men accountable for
their violent behavior it's accepting
that feminine is not antithetical to
masculine and vice-versa it's a world
where being a man encompasses both of
this
and this dark and Sun incomplete and
more